[Applaudissements]
guy lafleur a été le meilleur joueur est
depuis flamboyant de son époque six
saisons consécutives de plus de 50 bus
deux fois joueur par excellence de la
ligue nationale trois fois meilleur
marqueur du circuit et surtout gagnant
de cinq coupes stanley dont quatre
d'affilée avec le canadien de montréal
si sa carrière avait pris deux ou trois
saisons à démarrer elle a pris fin
abruptement
1984 après 19 matches il n'avait que
cinq points dont deux buts une
production en deçà de ses attentes
dînatoire
c'était le dernier but de la carrière de
guy lafleur âgé de seulement 33 ans il
surprend le monde du hockey en annonçant
qu'il accroche ses patins sur le chat
sur l'interphone en vue
j'annoncerai décision
monsieur car les ach avant
que je te bouffer un mal de tête
le canadien organise une cérémonie on
retire le célèbre numéro 10
trois saisons plus tard lafleur décident
d'effectuer un retour au jeu âgé de 36
ans il est invité par les rangers de new
york et le numéro 10 qui porte la 44
lors du camp d'entraînement étant à
nouveau le monde du hack et en faisant
une place dans l'équipe dirigée par
michel bergeron les grandes
retrouvailles avec le public montréalais
auront lieu en février 1989
ovationné longuement lors de la période
d'échauffement la flamme fera exploser
le forum comme à ses belles années avec
une performance de deux buts et une
passe les canadiens gagnent le match
mais la flore reçoit la deuxième étoile
le public est comblé l autre côté c'est
pour tous à l'entretien des paravents
[Applaudissements]
guy lafleur a ensuite bouclé la boucle
en allant disputer deux autres saisons
là où tout a commencé à québec ces deux
derniers matchs dans la ligue nationale
seront discutés dans l'uniforme des
nordiques contre les canadiens ils
seront des déclarations d'amour à son
endroit
[Applaudissements]
cette fois il pourra prendre sa retraite
avec le sentiment d'avoir complété son
oeuvre du lafleur a été le meilleur
pointeur de l'histoire des canadiens
devant jean béliveau et le deuxième
buteur derrière maurice richard comme
ses prédécesseurs
guy lafleur aurait été le coeur et l'âme
des canadiens faut jamais oublier que tu
joues ok c'est pas un travail c'est un
jeu faut s'amuser
il faut toujours gagner le plus possible
à l'automne 2010 9 l'idole d'une
génération guy lafleur est frappé par la
maladie
deux fois plutôt qu'une deux mois après
un quadruples pontage il doit subir
l'ablation d'un lobe du poumon touché
par le cancer les messages d'appui sont
venus de partout faites comme moi et
rejoignez l'équipe de guy l'argent oui
arrive à quai on donne moins bien sera
gris un an plus tard je vous livre fait
rire est venu et faites un don pour
l'appuyer la recherche sur le cancer
pour son dernier tour de piste lafleur
est retourné à ses origines la ligue
junior majeur du québec a retiré son
numéro quatre en commençant à gatineau
tout près de tueur sont là où il est né
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est à québec que les partisans
iront le saluer
lors du dévoilement d'une statue à son
effigie l'homme parlera encore avec son
cas je me souviens qu'à l'époque que
c'est un déjeuner avec jean béliveau
chez lui puis
il me dit être heureux
ça prouve sa poursuite
alors je les dessine à vinça pensa
possible que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]